hi i'm tony hinchcliff and this is
valuetaining questions i'm just testing
it
oh
valuetaining questions
that's exactly it
hi i'm tony hinchcliffe and this is
valuetaining questions with a comedian
what made you get into comedy i was
always getting in trouble in school and
i liked making people laugh i didn't
have a father in my life i was raised in
a super poor
dangerous neighborhood and all of those
things are reasons why a crazy mom of
course older siblings all of these
things
led me down the amazing path of being a
comedian
it's amazing he is uh touring with joe
rogan is fantastic it is uh you know
we're living that life uh don't believe
anything that you see on the news kids
because we are thriving out there
um we just did a sold out arena on a
wednesday 4 20 just this two what was
that the day before yesterday 15 000
people on a wednesday it's so much fun
lots of steak lots of beef jerky lots of
meat not in a gay way
not that that would be bad
a joke that i regret i once accidentally
called jimmy kimmel's aunt the c word
late at night at the comedy store she
was one of the only audience members i
asked her a question she responded with
a really smarmy answer
and uh
to entertain the other people in the
room i called her the c word i had no
idea it was jimmy kimmel's aunt until
the next day
i was asked uh did you call jimmy kimmel
xanthe c word last night at the comedy
store and then i realized that it was
indeed jimmy kimmel's aunt she wrote a
letter to all the big agents and uh
my friends in la i know because they all
told me like laughing like what did you
do to this poor lady
but they wrote she wrote them all
letters telling them not to work with me
luckily i didn't want to work with jimmy
kimmel in the first place you dork
[Laughter]
offensive coordinator for a football
team i'm good at calling plays i don't
know if there's any madden people in the
room but i would crush you i'm a
strategic strategic executioner of play
calling
well i mean plays are different it all
depends on the exact moment but uh you
know i like your go-to third down third
and long what do you go to third and
long i mean again it's it depends on the
team depends on exactly what's going on
but uh i would go uh
i mean that's not really how it works it
all depends
but i would go you know in that case
since you think i'm gonna pick a passing
play i'd go with a half back draw where
it appears as if though we're going to
pass he hands it off on third and long
and then it crushes you when i get 13
yards on a running play on third down
and now your morale is shaken
and then you think i'm going to run a
regular run play on the next first down
that i just got but then i'm passing it
you see what i mean you're all [ __ ] up
and i'm already dancing in the end zone
if you could fight any historical figure
mike tyson in his prime because if i
somehow land that lucky punch and get
that win how cool is that a lot of
people probably answer hitler there but
i mean
this is my point is like what if he
lands a lucky punch and you lose a fight
to hitler
what a loser
who the
wrote these questions this is incredible
of your life i mean they'd have to be
great johnny depp or something like that
someone super cool that can really tap
into the inner [ __ ] that is me
oh thank you hell yeah
i like that i think james franco might
be a little uh
too good looking to play me i like the
fact that i'm unlikable i think he has a
likable face
women like him right what fictional
character would you like to go out and
party with the nature boy ric flair the
true wrestling character that flies in
jets and drinks heavily and
does everything that humans want to do
if you could roast one person who would
it be and why really literally gotten to
roast the people that i wanted to roast
snoop was one of them you could find the
clip of that right underneath wherever
this is
i've got to make fun of elon musk a week
ago that was fun he's a goofball i live
my dreams so
what's the random stats out of your life
that you would want i don't know whoever
wrote these questions not only should
they be fired
they should be slowly tortured
physically in every single way oh i bet
they're not here
i bet they're like i'm gonna leave these
idiots with these questions and they're
all gonna look stupid
meanwhile he's out dipping his fries
into a wendy's frosty right now
i ate steak
really really really i eat at the best
restaurants five six nights a week it's
a serious problem
i ate two steaks on a jet on wednesday
and one on the ground
after we landed what's your celebrity
question
ooh i don't really um
have one that i could say
that
my girlfriend won't get mad at
martha stewart martha stewart yeah who's
hotter than that would you let her spoon
you uh-huh yes i would there was there's
there's actually nothing that i would
love more than to be the little spoon
with martha stewart just maybe on a
stack of cash
you know what i mean just [ __ ] after
a good hearty meal i want her steak
you know what i'm saying
ander roast beef too
martha stewart baddest [ __ ] on the
planet worked with her on the roast of
justin bieber and you can find the clip
of that right here right underneath this
thank you i'm tony hinchcliffe this has
been valuetaining questions with a
comedian
uh be sure to check out kill tony on
youtube
and
come see me live tonyhenchcliff.com for
tickets i'm on tour right now
[Music]